[Music]
thank you
hey everybody we've got a smooth starter
did you got to join everybody else in
I messed that out completely oh wow
that's you might you realize I'm still
on my holidays and I'm here with Matthew
is running the computer badly and Harris
might still be a little bit drunk from
yesterday's Shenanigans just a tad a
little bit but he's dressed up as the
corny little Viking that he is
and we are hoping fingers crossed that
we are going to be joined by Danny De
Gandalf very shortly as well but who
knows but I'm only going to be with you
for 15 or 20 minutes or so so um and
then I've got to drive home
I don't want to go home
I like um
cyworks hole you're not here though
where are you Dundee
I need a link I'll send them a link I've
sent him a link haven't I
but anyway guys we are in a Halloween
um special we're going to be talking
horror movies we love we're going to be
discussing what sort of makes a good
horror movie and then we're going to be
discussing why Paris Thor a viking was
scary
40. and then we'll go with that okay not
not a demon Viking zombie Viking
I'm a 40 grab your costume and run kind
of Viking you know excellent well we are
now going to be joined by oh grab your
costume
[Music]
hello everyone
uh we have got some bad reasons
got some evil gremlin
you kick him off
Wizards aren't used to actual technology
just yet
his magic is weak
Gandalf we'll get done it again off back
in and then we'll get started
all right all right
so at this point
right so guys before we get stuck into
then we normally do our little bit we
say well what have we watched this week
um I'll start because
um between beginning on my holidays and
being working full-time I've watched two
things of interest for this channel
I watched the new stand door episode
amazing there's there's absolutely like
two things happened in two episodes
is this any better much better yeah I
apologize I uh have a new setup today
new my camera I knew you know got it all
new stuff from the old house I'm no
longer on the laptop so
God help me I hope it's better anyway
sorry about that no worries you're with
us that's all that matters yeah somebody
of course didn't send me a link to the
stream we want
okay
yeah I'm blaming you
but Matt is actually running the show
today so it's Matt's fault so let me
just turn uh you sent a link yesterday
I thought I did exactly I just fell back
in the chat and sent the same link again
oh God hello so I am doing it by hand
today right now but anyway I was just
saying the way I've watched this week
because I've only watched a couple of
things and I literally watched Andor
which I thought was brilliant because
actually like something happened again
it's two weeks in a row three
and lower decks which I adored that's
not just my favorite lower decks episode
that's like one of my favorite startup
episodes in ages it was really really
good and that new ship the new automated
ship even though it's going to kill
everyone and I've not seen the last
episode yet so no spoilers for
apparently it's back
um it was just brilliant is that this
automated drone ship and I'm just like
have you never watched Star Trek that's
going to try to kill everybody
um
and apparently it does the biggest cross
would be awesome
but yeah actually genuinely good Star
Trek not just good lower decks I was
really really impressed by as you can
tell by my hyper choice
but um how about you guys what what have
you enjoyed this week in the world of
sci-fi or whatever
well I'll start off
um oh sorry oh me uh so yeah so much
I've been uh continuing on watching uh
She-Hulk this week uh got a couple of
episodes in and I haven't gotten to I
don't know if I've gotten to the point
where Jamie you were complaint or were
complaining about uh the woke episode I
don't think I got there yet
uh she she's navigating her dating world
right now
and of course I did see Andor this is
it's it's really I really like it it's
really good storytelling you know it's
uh
I like that um Andy Circus was thrown in
there
um I'm curious to see if that I don't
I'm curious
curious to see how that works out with
his character
um
also watched and then just saw Harris in
the corner of my eye forgot he was
dressed up
against myself sorry
Paris I do love your hat
I also watch the original uh miniseries
uh Stephen King's The Stand
um
very good isn't it it is very not not
the recent miniseries but this is the
the mini series that um oh God I guess
it came out
mid 90s
the recent one with the Goldberg and
that I thought that was great
yeah this is not that version this is
the earlier miniseries
the rats are his and uh then I watched a
lot of I found this um
list of uh
of
um XBox uh X-Files episodes to watch for
Halloween so I've kind of been working
it's like a batch of six or seven so
I've been working my way through those
those are kind of cool
yeah they always did a good good yeah
they did they really did
and of course then you know
um the annual Simpsons Halloween Special
which
is on point and awesome
[Music]
I do imagination this time didn't they
so it's like a different version of that
I like how every year they do a
different version of home or what have
you right and and all I love reading the
credits you know the credits anyone's
got their Halloween name
not something
foreign
it is I desperately need water at the
moment it's it's my life blood right now
what you've been watching this week I
don't see anything good
uh this is the first time I don't think
I well no I did go to the movie theater
on Thursday I've only been to the movie
theater I think twice this week I know
so so few times but uh I saw pray for
the devil
no
it had decent acting but besides that
uh-huh not not the best but um
I saw tar on Tuesday which is Kate
blanchett's new film and it's her
Michelle yo for the Oscar when come
February but that's a very like
complicated composition film like
composing yada yada
it's great though it's hard to follow
for to some degree but it was great uh
besides that Andor and tales of the Jedi
were
perfect on Wednesday to watch and uh
I think that's it besides just catching
up on Stargate I'm like half the way
through season seven on Stargate now so
I'm loving it
yeah
lintel
um you know the section 31 series that
was been banked around for a while that
the ones today starring Michelle yo that
um it's not happening because Michelle
yo is going to win the Oscar or at very
least get nominated and uh
she she's then not going to do staff
treatment those last couple of movies
has been brilliant and
instead of put the file nail on the
coffin so I'll go do something else
she's excellent Michelle yo is amazing
at Star Trek Discovery is the best thing
to Discovery oh my God you're right yeah
section 31 series would have been
phenomenal and yeah looks like it's not
happening damn it but anyway how about
you Matt what have you watched this week
because I know you've watched virtually
nothing because you've been
so absolutely nothing I've watched
we always
let's make it up I watched I watched
lots of horror films
um I watched lots of sci-fi
now I've watched absolutely nothing this
week uh other than you know the the
terrible TV you get on regular nighttime
television
and now it also I wanted to say this
when Harris was speaking I love how you
uh going to the theater twice in a week
is
I'm lucky to go like once a year
my neighbor actually I saw Black Adam
again with my neighbor and it was the
first time she's been in a theater in I
think four or five years
tonal opposites I feel my story in the
cinema was uh the last Star Wars film
so that was like what four years ago
you know you'd be like wanted to take
your kids to the cinema and you won't be
able to
gonna happen
all right
before I run off because the wife wants
to go home
um and I want to stay here but
um he lost just Matt
sign language I don't but we're gonna be
talking about some of the great horror
movies from over the years and some of
the favorite ones I'd love to know what
goes what sort of thing scares you in a
horror movie or what doesn't what's
stuck with you but before we um I don't
know what Matt's doing Matt's changed
they're not working they just go with
something else
my headset's not working give me a sec
okay we can hear you now
um
but I wanted to start off by talking
about two of the like sci-fi horror
movies that I think are the probably the
best two and that actually both of them
completely bombed at the cinema and
nearly you know nearly were forgotten
and also the the critics slammed both of
which is also always a good sign that
the film's going to be pretty good but
Event Horizon and the thing so I mean
James Cameron actually said that like
the original director I forget his name
from the from the original thing from
years ago actually stopped taking his
calls because the critics and things had
slammed the thing so badly when it was
released they said the special effects
were rubbish and and it's too over the
top and just just everything
if you look back at the thing now with
Kurt Russell
I mean that's still that stands up today
James Cameron is still not bad yeah
James Cameron is the mother knows what
he's doing when it comes to making a
movie right
oh I would say so a few billion dollars
also proves him right yeah never bet
against James Cameron no don't do that
exactly he he knows what he's doing even
when films go massively production
production companies put up with it
nowadays because they've learned his
lesson they've learned their lesson
um but for me I always thought the thing
was
um it's it's the perfect monster movie
yeah the special effects were great the
stories there the acting and the the
casting was just perfection
um but that movie absolutely bombed at
the cinema you know it it took it took
40 million dollars out of 60 million
budget which is bad but it went on to
become
you know the classics
uh um am I lose am I losing you guys are
you losing me I think we're losing you
yeah
[Music]
and then you complain about biscuits and
I don't know why right guys I will say
goodbye because I knew the Wi-Fi was
gonna suck here and it was going to
cause a problem so you guys talk and I
will get in the comments
all right I will be at home next time
please talk
to the cinema for me okay
see you later
okay well basically
you guys already know but the the
commenters won't know I am a horror
movie virgin
I was debating whether or not to say
that on stream but I'm a horror movie
virgin I've only watched a handful of
horror films
life so I didn't think it was fair for
you to come on and you know start
talking about films I know nothing about
when I can just ask you
to tell me your favorite films
I can then decide which one I like
and I'm gonna watch it I'm gonna pledge
that I'm gonna watch a horror film and
break
the virginity
okay
so who wants to go first
then let's throw Harris under the bus
all right all right
well uh
in in this the spirit of sci-fi of
course and horror
did you see of nope when it came out
earlier this year that was the most
recent horror sci-fi that I can think of
was that the Jordan peel Jordan peels
note with Kiki Palmer and Daniel kaluya
the guy from black I was wanting to go
see that but I never got a chance is it
streaming anywhere
that
well hold up I got IMDb right here okay
but uh me skills
I'm not that much of a computer guy I I
can't I can't be I I'll show off but uh
that's about the extent of my skills
right there
uh
I don't know where it tells me on a
computer honestly I always look at my
phone oh my God that means it might not
be available yet no no um
it should just tell me yeah no I'm not
sure exactly where to watch it it should
give me a where to watch on there
but if it's not available yet it should
be soon and it is
I really liked it I after kind of
sitting on it for a little bit it
it got worse and better in different
ways but I think the horror element of
it is the still that is definitely the
strong point so if you want some sci-fi
that is horror that the Sci-Fi is kind
of like the fun part that people are
like oh what goes on we're sci-fi nerds
over here that's that's our heart that's
our core we like that you know the horse
elements stay there so it's it's good it
gets get your sci-fi and horror there's
kind of like a a creature aspect to it
and it's it's fantastic it's kind of
like almost
Jaws meets Close Encounters the Third
Kind I've seen people say that but it's
it's more modern and of course Jordan
Peel's variation of it and it's
fantastic
in certain ways
I am just reading off about it so it's
called nope did you say yes nope nope
looks pretty good I'll probably check
that one out
um when you were talking about it being
released it was released on DVD about
five days ago it probably won't be on
any streaming services yet
okay probably not too far then at least
thankfully yeah no busy yes see Jamie
knows Jamie knows
all right Danny Gandalf what you got
okay so one of um
I don't know if you call it sci-fi but
it definitely is hard oh yeah it is kind
of sci-fi uh there was a series on AMC
some years ago that started out called
the terror
the two it was about this uh expedition
of this uh
this uh English ship it was on
expedition across the Arctic Circle
and the it ran across uh some uh some
Inuit people
that uh controlled this Beast it looked
like a polar bear with a human face
and the way it was filmed and the way it
was presented
was damn amazing I mean it was a what's
the star's name was Jared Harris
oh Jerry Harris is great yeah he he was
the main character and I don't want to
give too much of it away and that was
the first season so it's kind of filming
like an American movie uh American
Horror Story where there was one season
was one set story and then the next one
was the terror infamy which was about
this uh
vengeful spirit that lived in this
Japanese internment camp here in the
United States something like manzanar
and it and there's a uh our favorite
um
uh Navigator uh uh George takai was
playing in in this in this film of
course he grew up in a Japanese
internment camp
so that I really did like the chairs two
separate stories but and one was kind of
a monster story and the other one was
kind of a spirit story ghost story and
oh my God were they good very very good
uh in terms of films
I think the the one that had the most
impact for me and of course there's lots
of sci-fi horror movies out there but
one had the most impact I think was
alien the original alien the Sigourney
Weaver and Tom scarrett
um
it was and I saw it the week it came out
back during
78 79 I think it was anyway in that day
and age it was considered to be so scary
that some towns banned it
I mean it was actually it was a banned
movie there for a while because it was
so frightening you know
and then not a lot of people had heard
of H.R Giger by that point which did all
this that design and land creature
design
um
and one thing I remember
the thing I remember the most about the
thing in the theater was during the 10th
scenes you can start to hear a human
heartbeat in the heartbeat would speed
up as the tension Rose
in in the film and I thought it was just
just amazing genius but you know at the
at the end of the film essentially it's
about the the lady and her cat that
nobody listened to
it sounds about right sounds about right
you know
listen to the woman they all get killed
and she just takes her cat home
I have actually seen alien so that's one
horror film I can say I've seen so there
you go
you're no longer a virgin we deflowered
you right here on live cam thank you so
much there we go there we go that's
that's one way to say that he stole it I
took it away
so in terms of horror films what do you
what do you guys look for what what
makes a good horror film to you for you
guys
um well I know it makes a bad one like
what was it um I forget which which one
it was it was like Jason in space or
something you know Jason X Jason X yes
thank you very much it was like really
really the Roman numerals 10th Jason
it's when it you know um I'm not much
into Gore or
um or splatter movies I did see I think
it was like saw three and the only thing
that was missing was the rib sauce
because it was very much kind of
cannibalistic just
flaming yawn that was still screaming
and wiggling you know it was just that's
all it was there was no real Exposition
there this is a real story that's just
yeah
you know I mean I've I've made my share
of horror schlock films it was just not
the the blood spatter
although there was blood an alien
I think these days the the
um
the films that are that go for the gore
really go for the gore they're going for
the Olympic gold medal and it's just
you know for me it's still it just still
has to be a story
yeah I mean same thing that makes a good
horror film makes a good film in general
it has to have a good narrative right if
it doesn't like tell that narrative
cleverly at least in some way
you're screwed yeah but thankfully there
are I mean the horror films are like
just built for a cleverness and just fun
I mean the whole aspect of it is where
can we fit in something to scare the
[ __ ] out of somebody real fast right you
know uh to for them to figure out and
figure out well I guess where to put
those things whether it be like
an exorcism movie or a slasher movie or
Blair Witch Project where you don't see
anything and it's just that's tension of
just running
you know they're all horror movies are
just as wide a genre as anything but
they got to have a good narrative yeah
yeah see the thing with me in horror
films I always avoided them growing up
because they never seemed just looking
at the trailers they didn't seem
believable
yeah and that's what that's the kind of
movie I like to watch is I I like it to
be a little bit believable
I like I like to if if I was gonna go
into it
and it was something that could
reasonably happen maybe it's a
futuristic thing maybe it's in the past
maybe it's present but it could
reasonably happen that would get me
invested that would make me want to
watch it
but that's probably the reason why I've
never really watched that many in the in
the past
well I mean that's actually like where
horror
can be great if
if if it makes sense and you can
actually follow the story and it makes
it feel more real that I feel like
that's kind of when horror is
excellent and not just kind of oh Gore
for the sake of Gore here you go it's
torture porn but we're we're having
we're having fun just for the sake of it
I guess I you know it just kind of it
goes awry fast but if something focuses
on that you you know they're they're in
the clear typically Silence of the Lambs
is a good example for that because
that's yes terrifyingly believable alien
is even though it's futuristic it's
still believable to a degree because
we're showing the things that we need to
to
be believable I guess whenever that
uncanny valley really crosses in a
horror film that's when you're you're
gone
yeah right I mean how uh stormy
mentioned sore
when he was when he was talking I've
never really considered uh it probably
is would you consider that a horror film
or is it more of a just a goal film
because that's what I would consider it
just a Gore film I've seen them I've
never I've never thought they were scary
as a hobby
the elements of the film were shot in
such a way that they have their shocking
moments where they scare the audience
and everybody screams and
that's kind of the only thing the movie
is it's just you know a series of inter
interlocking events that just have
shocking moments of you know [ __ ] coming
at the screen to carry it essentially
you know uh I mean it it's not like you
know we were talking about the terror
which isn't actually it's an engrossing
story it it has you know care you you
learn you have you're emotionally
invested in the characters
same thing with with the thing
you you were invested in the characters
and their fate like I said saw three the
only thing missing was the rib sauce
you know yeah I saw uh you know Shelly
and Chad said yeah I saw it was horrible
and she's
when you're focusing on who's going to
die next and how they're going to die
versus
the character story and then oh [ __ ]
they're about to be in their death scene
or this could be their death scene right
here right yeah the narratives off in
your own head you know it makes you not
you're not watching a movie anymore
you're watching a YouTube video for
certain Clips yeah
um
it gets to the point where
the cut when you're watching a film like
saw you know everyone's going to die
it's just waiting for the moment
you know it's gonna happen but how is it
going to happen and then that's
that's the entertainment but it's not
I don't know I never found them
scary
which is why I wouldn't say it's horror
it it was great and it was shocking but
it wasn't scary
it loses its tension in a lot of places
like honestly the way it's kind of set
up even though it's not people running
away it is people running away sort of
they're kind of just chained up and of
course all these different things but
it's similar to The Blair Witch Project
or the thing where there's something
that we're not really seeing all the
time going after all these people and
they have to find a way to get away but
they just don't have that same type of
tension the thing or or Blair which
project does and Blair which project
achieves it with absolutely nothing but
a camera and just running in a direction
which is
great oh that's the that's the handheld
film yeah
yeah
I've not seen that but I I want to
that one holds up it's it's the reason
all the Paranormal Activities happen to
all of that that whole genre
because of that but that helped push
that genre and it's oh it's good their
Witch is great
now on another one and this may be a
little bit controversial but the one
that I really
got my heart pounding and had a lot of
you know tension inside me was the Mist
I don't know if you guys remember this
there's this scientific facility open
this parallel universe and out crawl the
monsters you know you have a lot of guys
they're trapped in this grocery store
and you can't see out and the the
challenge is to get out and survive and
it started like Thomas Jane of uh the
expanse Fair
it really um
I mean to me it really was uh scary and
then of course the horrible tragic
ending that I once for our audiences
but I thought that was a really good
sci-fi horror film I mean it was
the Mist is awesome they're making a TV
series on it right now oh are they
really but right there is going to be
always my favorite oh great
do you think is that going to be a
continuation or is that going to be a
re-imagining just in TV form
I would assume just a reimagining just a
different format of it okay because they
they have an older movie from
the late 70s maybe late 80s I might be
just I'm generalizing those decades and
uh frankly
way back when uh the Green Mile guy
redid it in I think 2005 2007. and so it
has literally
half of The Walking Dead cast in there
which is great because it's the same guy
that directed in the show ran the first
two seasons of Walking Dead so
there you go a lot of Walking Dead and
an expanse guy with Thomas Jane so life
is good that's a great movie
Lee has asked if I've watched Outland
with Sean Connery so we're the Western
type film in space I have not have any
of you guys great great great movie
loved Outland it was it was it was kind
of a departure for Sean Connery at that
time
um it probably been a departure for just
about anybody but it was really good
it did have this Wild West Field this
Western Field even though it was at a
space station
hmm
I must check that one out oh wow
David just said the Mist actually
already aired on Netflix and it got
canceled after a single season
well crap
see I'm just friends
I was gonna watch it
good shows on on uh Netflix they come
and go like your favorite characters on
House of the dragon or game yeah he's
just like oh yeah all my friends are
here to die
there I mean hopefully that's the only
good thing about that ad tier that's
coming on Netflix is hopefully with ads
they're like we've got extra cash
keep the good shows
hopefully people keep watching
right because they don't advertise their
stuff so how are they supposed to get
new subscribers on new shows if you
don't that's a whole different topic for
a whole different day but yeah yeah
the Netflix model part two yep
good Lord I got opinions about the uh
the Netflix thing hmm
you know he has opinions
as a poor person I have opinions
so there's
there's a great sci-fi horror movies we
have there there's kind of two more I
guess one is the crow
D I thought the crow was very well done
kind of Science fictiony in a way you
know it was a spiritual aspect of
main character being infused with the
spirit of the crow but I just want to
throw that out uh but the one that we
really need to talk about I'm serious
about this well this is the one that
cannot go unmentioned
and that my friends is The Rocky Horror
Picture Show which is the epitome of
sci-fi and horror
in lack of unreacting to a wonderful
bubble it's great I have see I have seen
that as well I love the rocky horror
pictures
it's that horror
oh it's it's fantastic
yeah I suppose but
oh I I love Rocky Horror there's there's
um like conventions that happen and you
it probably happens in America as well
um my message really wants to take me to
so we can dress up as a
at the late night double feature picture
show I want to go go ahead sorry I'm
just reminiscing oh no Danny Gandalf
Tunes over here I love it that's that's
how all the hobbits hang out right
Hobbits in the time warp baby now that's
a party there we go there we go
no uh What uh what is it Joaquin said
what about the Exorcist with Max von
Saito
I don't know if it's necessarily A
sci-fi horror but it is one of the best
horror films easily it was really good I
you know I remember you know the line
that has stuck with me for all these
years has been him yelling out you know
killed them all let God sort them out
yeah I've heard that phrase before but
the way he delivered it
got my attention
yeah it was it was extremely iconic
I haven't I've seen The Exorcist as well
I can talk about The Exorcist yeah and
the original is so much better all the
different remakes have been awful not
necessarily awesome the one I Recaps
from the 70s
yes the old one the old one they are
doing a direct sequel to it as we speak
I don't know if they're filming right
now or post-production pre-production or
what but it's it's got all the the
remaining cast it's still alive and
didn't die off in the first film so
that was good they'll be back they're
Top Gun mavericking um The Exorcist of
course
nice
I did like the Exorcist it was one of
those films
I completely forgot that I'd seen it
until someone mentioned it
it's good but I used to watch it all the
time when I was younger
I wonder how Exorcist would be if
somebody reimagined it as like a priest
Road buddy movie you know
two two out of control priests go across
the United States town to town searching
Out the Devil
it's exercising random women just right
you know
they get in their God mobile and they
cruise up to a Waffle Hut and expel the
demons
there's there's something there right I
mean it could be a thing
I I think that's the plot to Deadpool
three that's what
Ryan Reynolds are doing
right damn us Halloween special yes
yes
oh God yeah
well I think one that we mentioned a
couple weeks ago because it came out is
is I'm still pretty privy to it I I
gotta say Hellraiser is one of the best
sci-fi Horrors in general because it's
very demonic but it also
it's not necessarily demons it's
literally all sci-fi it's just it's it's
different dimensions and certain
I don't know how to necessarily explain
the the Box there's a puzzle box I don't
know if you've seen house uh Hellraiser
or Matt or not but there's a puzzle box
that you have to
a person starts and then once they
get one section of the puzzle done their
hand or whatever they're using to finish
the Box typically gets stabbed and that
kind of summons what seems to be a demon
but the really xenobites which is a
whole
altered Dimension kind of being it's
terrifyingly great and it is really
super sci-fi at its core and most people
don't even realize it they're like
demons popping out some Satan's [ __ ] no
it's not but I did mention this in one
of the previous lives I was in the is in
the chat
I I I know who Pinhead is how Horizons
oh yes I never watched it because of
what I told you I went to one of these
it was Halloween it was in Blackpool
which is like the budget Vegas of the UK
um
we I went to this like horror thing
where you walk through and it's like an
escape room but you just walk through
and then things jump out I got chased by
this Pinhead guy and it proper scared me
and I was like I don't want to even
watch that because he scarred me for
life
that's all the more reason to now right
it was almost 15 years ago so I think
having enough time has passed wow scare
this year out did we decide last week
that Pinhead is now a Disney princess
did we decide that we did the status
that has been confirmed Pinhead is at
Disney princess one officially
established xenobites are all Disney
princesses in a way
um I guess so now is Tim Curry
interesting you know as Dr frankenfurter
Dr frankenfer he's definitely a princess
okay
I don't know if Disney's the right
version of it but he's a princess
but no Hellraiser is fantastic if you
are going to check it out I I like the
new one a lot but I would watch Clive
Barker's original one first
you don't necessarily need the sequence
but because they're they're all varying
degrees but the first one is just still
it's terrifying talk about some torture
points and there's Gore and stuff but
it's it's
narratively meaningful so keeps you
there
hmm
well okay here's a question for you both
okay if you could if you could pick five
five horror films sci-fi or not it can
be any any horror okay ranked from five
to one what what would be in your top
five oh [ __ ] your favorite for best or
what
hmm so just top five so either because
it's really scary or just because it
left an impact on you in some way
well that's a hard question
yeah maybe we should do top three maybe
we should have top three
top three
uh well uh I would have to say some were
in my somewhere in my top three I don't
I don't know what the rank would
actually well one would have to be alien
because that one really did scare the
hell out of me at the time
um oh I here's another one okay so this
probably in the science fiction genre
scared the absolute crap out of me I
don't think I've been more shocked more
terrified more
uh negatively affected than this one
film this one film for me Takes the Cake
of horror movies okay you ready
The Wizard of Oz
my grandparents thought it was a great
idea to show me Wizard of Oz at the
tender age of three and those goddamn
flying monkeys lived in my closet I knew
it for a fact and I had to sleep with
the damn light on for the next four
years
that's it 40 years
that is a very surreal film I can see
why you'd be scared
I it's just in terms of like shaping
your life
Wizard of Oz for this three-year-old was
terrifying
that'll do it my my first memory Mr
Danny Gandalf over there is of Lord of
the Rings The Return of the King the
first film memory I had so what that
came out in 2003 so I was foreign
24 in February we're getting there not
not that fast but that's a good thing
but uh
I the first film memory I have is Gollum
turning into Golem so smeagle turning
into Golem jumping on I don't remember
his brother's name but killing his
brother and taking the ring and then
Smeagol yeah
it's deagle there we go Smiggle
[Music]
that's my first film memory and that's
it's not that scary now but it still
gives me just it brings the kid back out
you know it's it's terrifying is it my
birthday present yeah
foreign
[Music]
mine's gonna sound generic besides
Hellraiser just because Hellraiser I
love Hellraiser that's that's what I
like to see in a horror movie but it's
The Shining and Silence of the Lambs
those are just you you watch them and
you're different after in a way
okay so this is we we have a very
cultured uh uh member of the human race
in our audience Lee Wilcox
but actually uh uh talked about The Cook
the Thief His Wife and Her Lover the
film by Peter greenaway
okay here anyway is probably one of the
best conceptual uh directors as ever man
he also had another film
um
called prospero's books
uh John gilga starting at it it was
literally it was a literally a film
about the Tempest
uh but yeah I mean just I mean talk
about name-dropping Lee Wilcox wins it
for today to Cook the Thief His Wife and
Her Lover a very a very very young Tim
Roth uh starting at
um it was essentially it's about this uh
London gangster that takes over a
restaurant
and also a very young Helen Mirren was
in that film and it was an
um oh what's this for uh something Gabon
Michael gambin's in here too yeah yeah
yeah
I mean
of uh of uh
of young actors that really made it big
later on so cook Thief wife love her and
wasn't that scary to me but
it was more of a
it's got an nc7 murder gangster Rampage
kind of film you know okay
I mean it's got an nc17 rating so it's
got to have some some meat to it yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh my god did it have
meat
the scenes you know in the in the meat
truck in the oh gee cooked Thief wife
lover please go see it
it's on my watch list now okay
Peter Greenway and also watch if you can
find it anywhere it's very difficult to
find you may have an easier time Harris
uh finding it where you live um
prosperous books excellent prospero's
books we have all been robbed I've got a
speech about this we have all been
robbed because prosperous books is not a
Criterion Collection film
if there has ever been a film that
deserves a Criterion release it is
prospero's books
period
huh you were saying about the Wizard of
Oz being
um a film that scarred you as a child
essentially
I I kind of unlocked a memory in my mind
so I don't know what the film was and
you might be able to tell me what it is
based on what I tell you but when I was
five six the Mr Bean movie had come out
and
I think it had been out for maybe a year
something like that
and it was on TV so my dad put in the
little VHS and we were going to record
it
unbeknownst to me he must have also
recorded something else because I took
the video out of the VCR
which is obviously not it wasn't Mr Bean
it was a film where I I started watching
I started watching it all started
watching it and halfway through
a woman is in the shower and someone she
just starts getting stabbed in the
shower oh yeah psycho Alf I don't know
is it psycho
yes
uh yes
okay so to my mind as a six-year-old I
was thinking oh this is like a I don't
know a build up to Mr Bean I don't know
like where's Mr Bean he got to that
scene and I had to turn it off I'm like
this isn't Mr Bean what the hell is
happening to Mr Bean so that was
that's my earliest film memory that I
can think of
and that might be the reason why I
avoided horror films all this time
and very well might be a good reason for
that yeah
expecting the happy Mr Bean popping up
halfway through you freaking Alfred
Hitchcock just
I don't know how how I got so far into
the film to see that though like I
didn't realize that it wasn't Mr Bean I
mean I thought I was I was
God
damn
um yeah
I don't know what to say you're looking
for Mr Bean you can come up with uh
psycho
wow
that would be uh
what do you think of Mr Bean have you
all seen that man vs B on Netflix with
Rowan Atkinson
no huh tell me about it I haven't but um
people tell me it's good
a series it's a series but it's all
they're all 11 minutes 12 minutes 7
minutes 15 minutes you know they're just
different variations of shorts but it's
Roan Atkinson who is kind of I guess the
general gist of it is he's a
kind of a dad that's lagging his the
wife's divorced him his daughter's kind
of like all right Dad you know kind of
pushing them away not the most
successful dude you know but he's he's
not very great at keeping a job so he
gets a job at house sitting and while
this really fancy couple that he's he's
got this super nice rich rich house that
he's house sitting for there happens to
be a bee that gets stuck inside of the
house and the entire series is Rowan
Atkinson trying to kill said B but let's
just say the the opening scene is him in
a court of law with the couple who owns
the house so I haven't finished the
series yet I have like two or three
little episodes left but that's that's
the gist of it right there
it was it did look really good
I really wanted some being Rowan
Atkinson and it's great
yeah
and no one gets murdered
no no
well
and what
maybe the B maybe the B
existence with Christopher Eccleston
anyone
I don't think I've ever seen it
Christopher Eccleston the the 10th the
Ninth Doctor not the 10th sorry the
Ninth Doctor
was
I think Thor the Dark World and there
was
um there was a British zombie film was
it 28 days
but he played a a colonel in or a major
in
is a zombie yeah that sounds like a
zombie
28 Days Later maybe uh yeah 20 days
later
okay okay
yeah
Christopher ecclestone as major Henry
West
major
Egleston's great
yes just not Thor the Dark World we
won't talk about that one
why can't we talk about the Dark World
I mean we can if you want to
oh Alan Taylor directed it
give us the Taylor cut I'm kidding I
don't know
he's campaigned for it you know but I'm
that guy's Grace
yeah he was the dark elf
um
I do love Chris Ferguson he had a series
that he in the UK
um
and it's all about autism
I think we've got autism I think he has
autism or he's with someone who has
autism and it's really good it's really
was that was that the a word
the a word yes yes
I wonder where the a word is streaming
let's not ask Harris he's useless at
these kind of questions
yeah I think it was a BBC it was either
BBC Channel
did you get access to our player on the
market
um
only if I had a VPN I could uh fiddle
with probably
um I mean I've got uh I've got I think
I've got BBC but I don't know
if I've got if it'll have that
I'd like to see it
add that to my list
we're coming up to almost an hour
let's recap what films you've we've all
mentioned and I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you which films I'm gonna I'm gonna
watch
one of the films that you've mentioned
that I definitely will watch is going to
be Hellraiser
okay
I'm gonna watch it yeah there you go
so I'm gonna watch Hellraiser
not sure when
the next one
with no one in the house that's when you
watch Hellraiser of course
right when you have all your puzzles
around you that's the best time to do it
that's all Hellraiser is if you have a
Rubik's Cube around you just toss it in
the other room just damn good advice
[Laughter]
there was a film you mentioned at the
beginning Harris that sounded pretty
good it was the
sci-fi horror
nope what's it called yeah no nope nope
I'm gonna add that to my list as well
it's good I like I love sci-fi and if
it's science fiction I might enjoy it a
little bit more
that I don't want to sidebar too much on
it but have you seen get out Jordan
Field's first movie
oh get out
oh neither one of you can get out that
is a fantastic horror film it's it's a
big social commentary as well but it's a
it's mostly a horror film I believe he
won first he not the first he won the
maybe the first Oscar for best original
screenplay for a horror film since
maybe not silent to the Lambs I can't
think of what the last one was prior to
it but it's in a very small category of
horror films of what an Oscar and like
best original screenplay kind of deal
that's good it is it is it is really
good and it's got a
sci-fi element is more of a a medical
kind of sci-fi element to it but it is
spine tingling in its own sense and
it'll it'll give you I would watch nope
first because I think get out is just it
was his first movie but I don't know if
he can ever make a movie as as good as
that I don't want to say that because I
got faith in the guy but um get out is
fantastic
nope is really good as well though I I
think that's a
a good one to dive in on you know
stormy mentioned the thing
and I have seen
things about the thing a lot
would you would you recommend that as a
film to watch I would say so I mean uh
the the thing was kind of foundational
for a number of reasons one being uh
science fiction horror uh but yeah it's
it's in a lot of people's top tens list
for that genre so yeah I would
definitely I had that
okay
so if you would I'll ask each of you so
the six films are three each if you were
to give me three films as something to
Wet My Whistle so start with something
not scary then something a little bit
scary and something very scary
what what would you what would you
suggest
in terms of not scary please start out
with The Rocky Horror Picture Show
uh I've seen that already
oh you've already seen it read this
right um and did you see the Mist
the mess I didn't know okay Mr that's a
good one yeah I would start off with
mist
I would say what do you think the next
film should be Harris
I have you seen The Shining
is that the film
with Japanese oh yeah
I've seen parts of it
that's worth I'm gonna add that to my
list and you've got a sequel technically
it did Top Gun Maverick first doctor
sleep with Ewan McGregor I think 2018 or
2019 I think it was 2019 maybe 2020 even
but you you've got a a legacy sequel on
a way so yeah you got two things to
watch there which will be fun
and probably the the LA last thing I
would suggest
and this gives you lots of uh lots of
things to watch I'd watch the two
seasons of The Terror
the
terrorist television series that's
correct on it was on the AMC
in the U.S if you only can get one
season
um
uh I would do season one start off there
I mean they're both season one and
season two are self-contained stories uh
if you're the one the whole horror shock
your system kind of thing I would go for
season one
okay stormy did you ever see the horror
TV show
fear itself
um maybe once
I'm not sure
it was kind of that American Horror
Story kind of Anthology in a way like
every week it was instead of every
season with something different every
week was something different and it was
like a mini series in a particular way
but I think they had a few seasons of
miniseries
and that is that is terrifying or at
least it was when I was younger I had a
I think I took a middle school horror
class and I got showed that and I was
and dragged me to hell and that I was
just like all right I'm in it four
movies are great but this is terrifying
um but fear itself is a good TV series
as well for both of y'all
everything
TV so I'm gonna I'm adding all of these
to it I'm making a spreadsheet right now
okay so while you make a spreadsheet I
got a question for the audience
there's another thing that really scared
me I guess I was 13 14. this was maybe
mid 70s it was on television
which was kind of unusual for the time
it was a it was a it was a movie of the
week if you guys will know what those
are
it was on television and it was a
it was this a couple moves into this
house now I've always been wanting to
know what the name of this show is
a couple moves into the house
they start renovating or something like
that and uh there was
uh in the foyer of the house there was
some trap door or gate that they found
they could explore down and there were
these monsters living in this underneath
the Earth underneath this house
and one of the and this is scary uh
scared me to death I remember my
grandfather taunting me because I was
scared of it grabbing my toes under my
sheets what
anyway
um
I remember the the family fled in like a
blue Volvo and that's the only thing I
really remember about the show and I
always wanted to know where you know
where the movie Buffs hang out that kind
of been I was wondering if there's a
Reddit
were movie Buffs hanging out to answer
questions like that
I'm sure there is there's got to be that
we've got to be some sort of right
together
yeah
it was like mid 70s it would have been
probably 75 76 ish the the whole Lee
Wilcox suggested the hole maybe we hang
out here thank you Lee that's exactly
right the the film Buffs are over here
we know what we're talking about
sometimes most of the time
yeah there'll definitely be some sort of
uh subreddit
oh yeah there's a separate it for
everything nowadays
there's even a side track subreddit so
if you have slightly read it go join us
#side Dragon everything
yeah I'm not seeing anything I'm looking
on IMDb for the whole
um
so I had a look I did Google the whole
the only one I can find is a 2009 film
yeah this is definitely mid 70s
oh the it's not correlative to this at
all but we haven't talked about it and
just uh just to mention it just a little
bit because it's really not a horror
film it's more of a thriller but it's
supposed to be like a creature Horror in
a way
does Tremors count for anything this
trimmers is just great yeah yeah I think
that would I think that would
trimmers is the best Kevin freaking
bacon man that's that's such a good
movie
I live right down the road from where
that was filmed
that's that's awesome I'd go visit the
set once once a week just for the sake
of it you you need to you need to the
there uh there's a museum here the
Museum of Western film I think it is in
Lone Pine California that actually still
has a lot of the props that was used in
that film
especially the creatures
give me the graboids I love it ah
yeah I love that movie that does look
good I've just quickly jumped on IMDb to
have a look at that have you never seen
trimmers I've never seen it but it looks
very much like uh the first thing I
thought of was Mandalorian
that's your first thing to start out
with that's your like not scary at all
dip your toes in the water have fun with
it it that is like trimmers they're all
right I'm they're like YouTube essays
they're video essays on this stuff
trimmers is the absolute perfect Bee
Movie it is the best like b-plus movie
that you could ever see that's so well
done
so well and it stands out absolutely
that's like number one I'll do
what how many have I got here I've got
eight
nine films
because doctor sleep is in there but
that's after The Shining yeah so what
I'll do is I'll pick one of them
I'll do it like a random dice I guess
and I will watch it at some point within
the next month and then I'll make a
video about it well there you go that's
a good idea
there we go
and if I don't make a video about it you
can rip me in the comments of course we
will
and you're welcome I do want little
clips of reactions throughout the video
of what you're watching because if
you're terrified it makes it that much
better right
that's a good idea I could feel myself
watching it
and you can have like so much
just you know
I think it'd be awesome
that would be good
okay
so we've been on for an hour I think
it's a good time to
say goodbye or should we stick around
for a little bit
well you know we can we can just always
shoot to shoot about something else
we could talk we could switch this
object and start talking about Stargate
God helps or something else I do have to
go to work later today but yes the stock
is some so what was all the the so this
Hemsworth fella is now going to be
let's discuss that yeah
he is now tied to being uh the next
Witcher he's replacing Henry Cavill
which makes him not available to do
Stargate anymore which kind of puts the
whole thing up
so we have no idea what's
what's going on now it's kind of all up
in the air and it seems to have
well as long as he wasn't actually like
show running
it it's just replacing an actor right
or is that replacing a producer as well
sure I think he was going to be one of
the top
one of the top yeah Runner a big
producer of some sort and now
potentially
okay okay
so interesting
so much
so I'm just going based on on what Jay's
put out there
um
but yeah it seems like he was originally
going to be
I don't know if it was going to be sure
Runner
it might have been it might have been
sure right now and I thought it was
really strange that he was going to be
sure Runner but
it was something big he was going to do
and it was he was gonna
I think I think it was they needed a big
name to attach to it kind of thing to
pique the interest but now obviously
he's now going to be the natural
uh it's not gonna happen
did he not do Witcher because he's doing
uh something else what was it uh
Highlander
uh because he's back in Superman
that's right that's right he just has
too many DC things and I guess
because James Gunn has been hired and is
only going to be there for four years
and they have technically four years to
revamp the entire DCU
I guess they're hopping right into it
which is why they were like yeah you're
not gonna have time for Witcher but also
whenever I posted on our side Trek
Facebook group that y'all should so go
join of course
there was the one of the comments that
was uh responding said that
the reason I think um Henry Cavill
wanted to play geralt so bad was because
he loved the character and the story of
The Witcher he loved the books the video
games both
and the showrunner as we know she's done
well I like the show itself I don't love
love the show but I like the show a lot
it's not really super Canon and heavy in
in many ways and I I the comment was
saying that he understands that and
Henry Cavill said all right if I could
play the Boy Scout again and actually
play him as a Boy Scout not some sad
depressive
Superman
he's kind of jumped on it I guess he'd
rather play a character that he
I guess can can stay in that character
and actually feel like he's he's being
the character that is we know and love
because if geralt's not going to be
geralt as much as
we'd like them to be
he's going to feel that first you know
same thing with Superman not being
Superman he's been the first person to
campaign
for
hey tone it down I don't need to be
snapping zod's neck in the back end of a
movie we should be
Superman I'm I'm the guy that's gonna
stop down and save the cat in the tree
and then keep going on with my day we
all want to hear Zod snapping don't we
I'm at the grocery store and I'm
thinking you know I'd like to be
snapping some Zod right about now
sorry go ahead
I do love Henry Cavill in in in the fact
that he is just a nerd
he is he's a nerd first and foremost so
anything that he does
you can tell he loves doing it
and when we first got made into into
geralt there was some interview I
watched and it was essentially him
saying that if if anything wasn't quite
right
I'd be like no that's not how it happens
it happens like this
I mean he just has a really good screen
presence I watched a YouTube video of
him this last week putting together a
gaming PC yep and you know he he he he
even stole the scene there I mean he
just has such a great screen presence
that's hard to take your eyes off of it
it's like you know um
kind of like Jason Momoa no matter even
when he was in Stargate Atlantis
he stole them near every scene just by
kind of standing there yeah
actors like that are really few and far
between and um
uh capital is the epitome
Jason Momoa in Atlanta it's one of my
favorite things with him
I think it must have been like the late
a season four or five I'm not sure which
uh but woolsey's in charge and Woolsey
has brought in this this thing where
he's like everyone has to write a report
and he's like I don't I don't write
reports because oh you can use this this
dictaphone you can you're just talking
because I don't talk either and then and
then they they have to say Atlantis and
at the end at the end he hands it hands
him this microphone thing and he goes I
wrote a report
and he plays it and all it is
um somebody's got into Atlantis we beat
them end of report
[Music]
end of report
I'm so excited I think I'm on episode 12
or 13 of season seven so I'm I'm right
there ah so you're you're up to the
point almost oh if you
've seen lost city is that that's season
seven isn't it
I haven't seen them get to it they're
searching for it they know of its
existence and they're searching for it
uh the last episode I watched is a
two-parter and I I'm blanking on what
they showed me in the first part of the
two-parter
um
oh oh it's it's when Daniel and I forget
the other scientists name are down in
the Amazon and they're looking for it's
it's when Anubis is introducing I guess
the the Gould super soldiers
all the co-warios yeah yeah okay I just
finished that first episode which was
good I'm I'm excited for more and and
was that the one where they all get uh
snapped up by some sort of uh Rebels
some sort of hunt yeah uh right right
prior to that was the all like Amazonian
Warriors in a way right
so that's when they're looking for that
Cube thing
yes yeah they just found the thing that
is the foundation for the sarcophagus I
think they said
okay yeah okay that makes the foundation
because because it's like the Fountain
of Fountain of Youth that was the whole
mythology right yeah
around
and it's some good stuff and I'm very
excited to kind of watch it that's why
everyone watching these seven is
fantastic but are you on the end of
season seven or you're at the beginning
uh like smack dab in the middle I where
I'm at is like literally either 11 12 or
13 so it's like
smack in the middle he smack dab in the
middle
I think the end of season seven
is
yeah the end of season seven I'm pretty
sure is like the greatest Stargate
you'll ever watch
Ed I'm pumped because that's that's when
Atlantis starts
is
it feels like the show
I mean the show is an entity in itself
in a way and you can I it it's in its
I don't I don't know I feel like it's
like right past its teen years in a way
in in seven season seven it's like
it just got into college and it's it's
it's now like kicking things up it's
ramping things up a bit you know I love
it it's just it's fun for for it's not
an old show necessarily but for
the age of a show it is it's fan it's
amazing I I I'm surprised I didn't know
about it when I was younger because I
would have ate it up I was I was very
lucky to have someone a little bit older
than me introduce it to me when I was
younger so I was about 12 when I first
found it and it I was hooked from the
very the very first I think I think I
must have started watching it maybe like
halfway through season four or five
so in 2003 when whatever season was on
in about 2003 2004 that's when I first
started watching it and then I was like
this is amazing I need to go back and I
watched all of them from them and now
I've watched it like 50 times over
go straight into the series
I didn't I didn't watch the movie first
I'm I'm one of them people I just I
found you from the the television show
but I loved I obviously loved the movie
the movie's fantastic yeah but I watched
that after the fact because I wanted to
know where did starvey come from and
then I I found it it's amazing
it's it's fantastic uh lee just said in
the comments how about Farscape I almost
chose to watch Farscape over sg1
has a bunch of fans but I'm so glad I
watched sg1 It's just Fosgate the one
that has been Browder and yes
[Music]
Claudia Black they both come in later
right and SG-1 right he's nine yes yeah
it's in Stargate that's um they they had
such great chemistry
and uh
in Farscape I really did love Farscape
really I like the concept of it I've
seen the first two episodes of it uh
the concept seems nice I like the whole
prison barge out in space but it doesn't
seem like it could last for four or five
seasons either it did it
did it could have gone a couple more
probably
because they were you know once you get
into uh understand what the peacekeepers
are and then you start getting into the
Peacekeeper War
um
I mean I just thought it was an
excellent series uh and uh Claudia Black
have been proud that they were just
excellent together on screen just
excellent together
and the puppetry from Jim Henson Studios
was just magnificent magnificent
that
you might have just given me a little
bit of an epiphany I Jim Henson might be
the reason I started watching Stargate
because I kind of whenever I saw the
movie I saw the movie and the TV show
all I mean I started with the movie but
the whole my whole decision making was
okay s star date or
Farscape
and I chose Stargate but the reason I
even had Farscape in mind was because of
Jim Henson I just watched Dark Crystal
resistance and
that that might be the reason I got into
this and after a few episodes you forget
their puppets that's how good she means
the studio and after a few episodes you
so it's hard to get you first you see it
and you see the first episode well
puppets really I mean it's
I mean but after a few episodes it is
the it is so good the acting the writing
and the puppetry so good you really
forget that they're puppets
how
uh
because I'm like you Harris I've not
seen that I know of it because
I just bought the whole thing but um I
just bought it up
um
I'm sure there's a way I can find it you
see it's it could be Hulu it could be
it's one of the or Amazon or something
um
but it is it is excellent
it is here let me look at my phone
you know Farscape is fantastic I I
really would like to see more Jim Henson
work just I I passed by the Jim Henson
company in La all the time and it's just
it makes me sad knowing that they're
renting out studios in there instead of
you know
using themselves sometimes which they
are to a degree but
I need more I'm still mad at Netflix for
canceling Dark Crystal
oh right that was that was just like you
know kick ahead
oh okay uh farscapes on freebie so it's
the Amazon Prime but not okay yeah yeah
okay yeah
I have Amazon Prime
free is good we like free
oh yeah I think
um I think it should be time to wrap up
because my my missus is asking me to go
and eat dinner so
she's gonna
throw of course she got it good
but thank you both for coming it has
been educational for me as as a horror I
I I guess we've determined that I'm not
a horror virgin as such I'm a horror
um whatever the the the the word for
Noob is when you haven't seen something
amateur
amateur yeah
once you get saturated with horror the
the the the then you have to really
after a game and you have to go and
watch something like I don't know Sound
of Music to really feel the terror and
the stretching
but you have to watch Sound of Music
after you've peaked on acid and that's
a whole different thing yes
more time on acid
yeah yeah once you know once you you
know going out in my backyard to dug up
some peyote
when the line comes up the hills are
alive with the sounds of music
then it kicks in man
do re mi fa so like you're just freaking
you out everything becomes the power
so you know the jackrabbits come you
know
we start vibrating the doe sound and
it's it's just yeah Sound of Music the
microducing I'm not sure that'd be a
really good actually that kind of really
does [ __ ] terrify me
foreign
but you said the hills are alive and it
made me think of by next Halloween Matt
we will work you up to The Hills Have
Eyes well we'll get you into some scary
things yeah you know there there's a
there's something that um gets some skin
crawling for you yeah yeah the hills
have a that's something you want to wear
you want to watch while wearing adult
diapers I think I've heard I've
mentioned before I watched it at like 10
or 12 years old for the first time and
that was not a good decision that was
not Paris was that last week it is last
month I've been Benjamin buttoning
yeah
oh geez
God we're terrible
all right
well I'll say thank you both for coming
it's been a very easy man for me it's
been
I hope everyone's enjoyed it
it's been fun I I've enjoyed it it's
been pretty good I've always enjoyed it
I get to run my mouth for an hour how
great is that
as always it's been a pleasure speaking
to both of you thank you everyone for
coming you as well let's roll the outro
foreign
[Music]